if there's one aspects of cognitive
performance that's worth enhancing then
it probably should be focus with more
focus you can work harder and longer on
a single task without being distracted
or without procrastinating this means
you can work on more projects get more
done as enough time in the day to
achieve amazing things but unfortunately
a lot of us just lack the focus and the
concentration to work on those things
and so in this video I'm going to talk
to you about how you can increase your
focus your concentration by
understanding a little bit of the
neuroscience behind it
so I've talked a bit about flow states
in the past and achieving heightened
states of awareness etc there's a lot
more to focus on concentration than that
so our ability to focus is handled by a
network of brain regions called the
salience network and this handles what's
called executive attention our ability
to focus on one task and to choose what
that task or that stimulus might be one
of the key structures in this brain
network is the anterior cingulate cortex
or the ACC and this is connected to the
hypothalamus in the brain stem as well
as the prefrontal cortex when this brain
region the ACC is damaged it can result
in massively lower levels of focus and
motivation in fact people who lose this
part of the brain or function in this
part of the brain they can end up so
unmotivated that they can't even move so
we know it plays a really important role
it not only focused but also motivation
because those two things are tightly
connected so we know that the prefrontal
cortex is responsible for our ability to
plan and to think ahead and meanwhile
our hypothalamus is partly responsible
for our emotional responses and this is
connected to our endocrine system by our
pituitary gland so you have your logical
reasoning motivation and you have your
emotionally driven motivation we can
also break the salience network down
into two separate other networks you
have the dorsal stream and the ventral
stream so an over stream and an under
stream the dorsal stream is responsible
for our conscious decision making our
conscious motivation and focus this is
when we decide I'm gonna focus on this
and we do it and then our ventral stream
is responsible for the other kind of
attention the emotionally driven
attention this is when we hear a loud
noise and suddenly we break from what
we're doing and we look over there at
what's happening or it's when we feel
uncomfortable so we can't focus because
we're just focused on how uncomfortable
we are and it's responsible for what's
known as the cocktail effects which is
where if you're a party and you hear
someone mention your name suddenly your
ears prick up because your emotional
response is connected to that sound and
you think something's important
happening something relevant to me is
happening it's dopamine in these brain
areas that tells us that something
important is happening so dopamine is
the reward hormone the reward
neurotransmitter and it's released not
as a reward for doing something but
actually to tell us that what we're
doing is important and would
driving towards a reward so dopamine
tells us to focus to remember what we're
doing and when this is released in the
relevant brain area our attention
switches that way via these streams
likewise we release adrenaline and
cortisol stress hormones other
stimulatory hormones and they likewise
shift our attention to things that we
might think are dangerous or scary or
otherwise worthy of our attention this
is all very interesting but what can we
take from this what can we practically
do with this information
well on the one hand we now know that
our emotions play a big role in focus
and this is what's so often missing from
our attempts to focus on a project we
think that our focus and our attention
is entirely about will it's about
planning and logic but actually a lot of
it is emotional and emote our motivation
is emotional you know that when you buy
something it's almost always emotionally
driven salespeople know this well
they'll try and pitch something to you
and they won't focus on the logic it
won't tell you this is a sensible
decision they'll tell you everyone's got
this product it's really cool it's
really exciting they'll tell you it
feels great in the hand they try and
appeal to your emotion because emotion
is very often what drives our
decision-making and our focus and
emotion from an evolutionary perspective
exists to tell us what's important for
our survival
so something seems important to our
survival or our status or our likelihood
of finding a mate or finding food then
it seems important and if something
seemingly has no survival value then
we're disinterested so that kind of
makes a lot of sense when you think
about it this is why it's so hard to
focus on entering data into a dull
spreadsheet or it's so hard to focus on
a book that you're not really enjoying
or to learn a language when it gets to
the difficult parts it tells you why you
often drift off in a boring conversation
because it's just not relevant to you
and your body is producing emotions and
hormones neurotransmitters to say
there's more important stuff going on
over here also tells you why it's so
hard to concentrate when there's noise
behind you because your brain is like is
any of this important it tells you why
it's so hard to concentrate when there's
something else you'd rather be doing
because your motivation your emotion is
dragging you in that position
but we can use all this to our advantage
if you understand that emotion is what
drives your motivation in your focus
then you can hack this system and use it
to achieve all kinds of things so one of
the things I struggle with is waking up
early
morning I find it hard to get out of bed
and I always tried to do the logical
thing you kind of CBT type of approaches
and tell myself why I need to get out of
bed why it's important and how lying in
bed isn't going to help me well I
actually found was the best way to force
myself out of bed was to give myself
something that I really wanted to do and
it was just a small step some emotional
reason to get out of bed and for me it's
checking my emails and my responses on
my youtube videos because that's
something I'm excited to do so even
though a lot of people say you shouldn't
look at a phone first thing in the
morning from me that's something I'm
driven to do so when the alarm goes off
at 5:30 or at 6:00 and I think I can't
love to get out of bed I think what I am
interested in knowing if there's been
any comments on my youtube videos and so
I grab my phone and I look at it and
that gives me enough kind of mental
stimulation to start coming around and
then getting out of bed is much easier
the next thing I want to do is get that
coffee so if you want to make yourself
do something you need to make it
interesting
emotionally emotionally motivating to
yourself in order to be able to do it
it's no good just telling yourself you
need to do it please do it come on we
have to do it now you need to give
yourself that emotional hook that
emotional reason to do it likewise if
you're working on an essay if you're
working on a project you need to give
yourself the emotional hook the
emotional reason to be doing that thing
if you want to stay focused don't just
be working on dry topics because
eventually you're just going to burn out
something else will see more interested
there's only so long you can sustain
attention using just that dorsal stream
you need the ventral stream to be
working with you so if what you're
working on is really boring and dull and
you find it hard to focus on it you need
to make it more interesting and the way
you can often do that is just to
remember what it is about that thing
that is the most valuable or most
interesting to you you can almost always
find something interesting about a topic
even if it's dull key part of my job
involves writing about the most boring
stuff have to write about car windows
have to write about bricklaying
sometimes not stuff that I have any
knowledge about orange or you know even
interesting for what I do is I try and
think well how can I relate this to
myself what what emotional investments
do I have in this topic so if I'm
writing about car windows are write
about things like attention and focus
because you need to be attentive to the
road that's why you can't have
cracked car window if I'm writing about
bricklaying I might talk about how it's
great for building grip strength so
these are things I'm interested in and
then I'm motivated to write those things
and that means I'm much less likely to
get distracted likewise you can just try
to remember the reason you're doing it
and focus on the emotional hook behind
that so if you're doing a job that you
hate and you're finding it really hard
to focus off you're washing up in the
kitchen picture how good it will feel
when it's done picture how good it'll
feel when your kitchen is nice and
pristine and when you're working bored
at work picture what it will be like
when you eventually get that promotion
and feel the emotional reason to carry
on working through like that what's also
really important is that you avoid other
ventral stream distractions so you can't
have the noises in the background you
can't have people chattering and you
want to take away things that you're
looking forwards to so if they're
something you're looking forward to and
that's taking up too much of your mental
space and you can't focus on what you're
meant to be doing then just tell
yourself I will be allowed to do this
later so if I'm too interested in
playing sonic forces I say to myself
once you've finished at 5:00 p.m. you
can play that so hopefully that's a bit
less of a distraction I can lock it away
in the back of my brain likewise if
you've got anything pressing that you
need to do if you have emails you need
to answer if you have calls you need to
make do those right away Tim Ferriss
calls them open loops I think i think
that was Tim Ferriss and this is
basically anything that's playing on
your mind and nagging at you taking away
your motivation in your energy and when
you get those done again it's easier to
focus on the big things you want to
maintain a state known as homeostasis
that's when you're neutral that's when
you're not hungry not hot not cold not
too excited not too tired so that means
you need to look after yourself
physically you need to make sure you're
well slept you need to make sure that
you're eating well you need to make sure
that you're not too cold or too hot
because these are things that will
distract you from what you're supposed
to be doing Matt Mullenweg of WordPress
Fame he says that he uses a technique
where he'll listen to music on
headphones and then he'll play the same
couple of tracks over and over again
because he knows it so well he
eventually becomes kind of desensitized
to it and this is almost like sensory
deprivation it completely removes that
distraction from him the audio
distraction and he can focus more on
what he's doing so find ways to tune out
the world make sure you are comfortable
make sure you take breaks and that's the
other thing I want to talk about because
focus takes energy especially dorsal
attend
using a prefrontal cortex having a plan
sticking at something and avoiding those
distractions using your will that takes
energy and if you're too tired you won't
be able to focus you won't be able to
concentrate so what you need to do is
need to make sure that you're well
rested at all times and this is the big
thing a lot of us think oh I'm gonna
write the world's best novel in the
evenings I'm going to launch my own
business I'm going to start a workout
then we fail and we say I didn't have
time well you did probably have time
because otherwise you wouldn't have
watched the whole box set of Game of
Thrones what you've probably not got
enough of is energy and again it's
likely emotional energy it's all of
those interactions with people there's
why it's good to do your most important
work the most important work to you
first thing in the morning once you've
still got all of that emotional energy
and all of that focus and also to try
and remove things stealing your energy
stealing your focus because you wouldn't
have any left at the end of the day
otherwise time your work around when you
know you work best and recognize that
your energy is a finite thing and that
you need energy if you're going to focus
and concentrate finally build lots of
small rewards into what you're doing
build lots of small tests response
reward because some things are naturally
very easy to focus on very easy to
concentrate whereas other things are
harder to do so wish when I'm editing a
video or when I'm programming I get into
a flow state I'm so focused I forget to
give the toilet and it's hard not to
when I'm editing I always get into that
state and that's the cause I have that
feeling of testing something small
checking it getting that reward so that
is the emotional goal that gives me that
kind of kick the reason to keep going
and then each time I go through the same
little cycle and every time I watched my
video that's a bit better or I run my
app and actually works and get a little
kick of dopamine that keeps me going and
this is why some programmers get kind of
so wired in or just wiring them and some
CEO who purposefully take advantage of
that nature to work them completely dry
I'm not saying that's a good thing but
you can build in these little rewards
cycles these tests reward cycles into
whatever work you're doing so if you're
writing an essay make sure you keep
looking at that word count go away for
10 minutes and type then check the word
count and then you get that little
reward or just make it look nicer zoom
out and think that's the work I've done
that little pang of rewards low dopamine
is one of the big reasons that we
struggle with focus and attention and in
fact a low dopamine in certain brain
areas is one of the most likely
explanations for ADHD in many cases you
can boost dopamine of course with
caffeine or with a bunch of nootropics
but using the techniques that I've
recommended here to boost it naturally
is far preferable on one last thing of
course practice if you practice with any
rein region it will get larger i've
talked on this channel a lot about brain
plasticity we know that like a muscle
training certain brain areas will make
them get bigger when I started out
writing essays full time as my career I
my goal was to write four thousand words
a day so in eight hours nine hours I try
and write 4,000 words today I write
sometimes as much as 20 or even 30
thousand words a day I start my mornings
I work for Android Authority until 1:00
and then after that I'll write at least
10,000 in the remaining few hours of the
day not bragging I'm just saying with
practice you can focus more on anything
so if you're not focusing right away
don't feel bad just keep at it keep
trying and eventually that thing that
specific task in particular will become
easier to focus on because you'll be
used to it and your brain will have
adapted we found this video useful and
interesting guys if you did then please
leave a like and comment down below I
love discussing these topics with you
guys and stay tuned for the next one
subscribe if you'd like to see more like
this hit the bell button for
notifications and I've got much more on
the way on body building brain training
fitness parkour martial arts nootropics
you name it got some cool ideas
hopefully that I'm working on right now
so yeah can't wait to share those with
you thanks so much for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now